we take pftpm earlier today i guess this
technically then becomes pftpm
ps because after we concluded our late
afternoon session regarding among other
things the situation in washington
the washington post article finally has
been published and it identifies
15 former female employees who claim
that they were sexually harassed during
their time
with the franchise now only one of them
is named
the other 14 have decided not to allow
their names to be published because of
non-disclosure agreements
that were signed that expressly threaten
potential litigation if they talk
about things that happen while they work
for
the team now to know more about
what exactly would have been a led by
them to the team and therefore to allow
us to know more about what maybe owner
owner daniel snyder knew at the time
these agreements were negotiated
we'd have to know more about the
specifics of the agreements it's
possible these are just
general severance agreements that these
individuals signed without
ever making specific detailed
allegations that would have put daniel
schneider
on notice that he has a problem but the
portrait painted by this story
reasonably would put him on notice that
he has a problem and even though there
are no specific allegations made
against him the three individuals who
are named as having
allegedly done things they shouldn't
have done larry michael
alex santos richard band ii all three of
them have
left the team in recent days michael
play-by-play voice of the team for 16
years abruptly retired on wednesday
and most people thought maybe it has
something to do with this story
clearly it did santos was the director
of pro personnel
man was the assistant director of pro
personnel they were both fired over the
weekend
so there have been consequences for the
individuals who are accused of
wrongdoing
you can reasonably conclude that
whatever investigation the team did
allowed it to conclude
that the individuals were responsible
for the things they were accused of
doing but no accusations
against snyder no accusations against
bruce allen the long time president of
the team
which makes this situation different for
snyder
than it was in carolina several years
ago for jerry richardson when the
founder of the team had to abruptly sell
the team
after it came out that there were
multiple non-disclosure agreements based
upon
allegations of misconduct all of which
trace back to him
in this case there's nothing tracing
back specifically
to snyder but the problem is this
everything traces back to snyder
generally
he's not an absentee landlord like other
owners who live in one
city and own a team in a different city
he's there
he's present this is his culture this is
his organization
he's been the owner for 21 years
if he's not aware of the things that are
happening
under his watch then he's clueless and
see
in order to avoid significant scrutiny
from the league office or his business
partners who own the other 31 franchises
snyder essentially has to characterize
himself as being
completely and totally clueless as to
the things happening
in his building and that's going to be
hard to pull off the article creates
the impression that this all began at
the top this
atmosphere began at the top how
employees are treated
specific allegation of daniel snyder
berating a male
employee no allegation of sexual
misconduct against a
female employee but comments made
allegedly by snyder
that would then trickle down because see
the person who runs the organization
does indeed set the tone and it's fair
to infer that the tone that was set by
snyder
was indeed copied mimicked perpetuated
by the people working
under him and the bottom line is if it
was as prevalent as these
15 individuals would seem to suggest
snyder
surely knew or at a minimum should have
known what was going on
so what happens moving forward we watch
and see what the reaction to this story
is how much pressure it creates for
the washington franchise how much
pressure it places on the league
and on other teams to account guys
will that be enough to force the kind of
action that would
result in snyder selling the team this
is why
he's hired an outside lawyer to come in
and conduct this investigation
he wants the end result to be daniel
schneider is blameless
daniel snyder knew nothing about these
specific activities daniel snyder had no
reason to go in and clean up a mess
because he didn't know a mess existed
again to sell that
he's going to have to be willing to make
himself look clueless either way it's
not a good look and either way depending
upon how things unfold
it's the kind of situation that could
create serious problems for his ongoing
ownership
of the team we'll surely have more about
this tomorrow on pft
p.m and throughout the rest of the
evening and into friday at
profootballtalk.com have a great evening
we'll talk again tomorrow
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports